Georges Marchais l'homme qui avait
choisi son camp documentaire écrire et
réalisé par Gérard Muller un portrait de
l'ancien numéro 1 du Parti communiste
français qui c'est vrai aura durablement
marqué le paysage politique français des
années Giscard et bien sûr Mitterrand
période aussi et peut-être surtout où le
grand frère soviétique connaîtra la
glaciation la pérestroika avant de vivre
ces derniers instants alors au fond quel
héritage Georges Marchais a-t-il bien pu
laisser au communiste français voilà la
question que nous avons choisi de nous
poser dans ce débat doc aujourd'hui
Gérard Muller est avec nous bienvenue
vous avez donc écrit et réaliser le film
que nous venons de voir vous êtes
psychanalyse professeur des universités
mais aussi écrivain chroniqueurs
scénariste réalisateur de documentaires
avec maintenant une bonne quinzaine de
documentaires de votre filmographie et
notamment un documentaire consacré à DSK
puis Jérôme Cahuzac et nous avions eu le
bonheur de présenter ce documentaire
consacré à dans cette même émission des
Badoc Fabien Roussel est également avec
nous sur ce plateau bienvenu vous êtes
député du Nord secrétaire national
autrement dit numéro 1 du Parti
communiste français et ce depuis 2018
vous êtes aussi amis de lycée et même
copains comme cochon dit-on avec Olivier
marchais fils de Georges Marchais qu'on
a vu bien entendu dans ce film qui fut
le coordinateur de votre campagne
présidentielle c'est une élection vous
est arrivé en 8e position on le rappelle
avec 2,28% des suffrages avant d'être
brillamment d'ailleurs réélu aux
élections législatives Roland Carol est
enfin avec nous vous êtes polytologue
auteur le président sur la corde c'est
votre dernier livre et il est disponible
chez Calmon Levy Gérard Miller c'est
toujours important un titre d'un film
d'un documentaire j'imagine que vous
avez réfléchi avant de le choisir et
puis vous avez choisi Georges Marchais
l'homme qui avait choisi son camp quel
camp a-t-il choisi Georges Marchais
maintenant que vous avez fait le tour du
personnage là il a choisi le camp des
communistes le camp du peuple et ce que
j'ai voulu notamment dire par ce titre
c'est qu'il a pas eu la chance comme
Obélix de tomber dans la marmite en
étant petit c'était pas une famille de
communiste c'était même une famille tout
à fait apolitique on découvre dans le
film comme il met entre guillemets
longtemps en tout cas il s'approche de
la trentaine il est syndicaliste il n'a
pas envie d'adhérer au parti communiste
et donc c'était intéressant de voir
l'histoire d'un ouvrier qui décide à un
moment donné de s'engager jusqu'au bout
dans le parti communiste c'est ça le
titre d'abord et avant tout que je me
suis dit Gérard Miller il a comme une
envie de réhabiliter Georges Marchais
alors que même dans votre parcours
politique personnel bon c'était pas
votre préférée
il faut l'expliquer au téléspectateurs
j'ai eu 20 ans 68 j'étais sur les
barricades tout début du mouvement de
Mai est au tout début du mouvement de
Mai Georges Marchais tape un raccourci
sur les gauchistes que nous étions donc
c'est ma première rencontre avec lui
mais ce que j'ai compris quand même
relativement vite c'est à quel point il
avait marqué d'abord le de la deuxième
moitié du 20e siècle et à quel point
c'était ce que je n'hésiterai pas dire
un héros de la classe ouvrière française
c'est-à-dire qu'il a incontestablement
marqué l'histoire de ce pays de la
gauche mais de ce pays et ce qu'on
ignore souvent puisque vous évoquez
Mitterrand c'est à quel point il a
permis à Mitterrand d'arriver au pouvoir
le Parti communiste et la force motrice
de l'union de la gauche elle veut cette
union de la Gaule le Parti communiste
veut c'est union de la gauche depuis le
début et pousse les socialistes en
quelque sorte à s'engager eux-mêmes dans
cette union vous évoquiez 68 un George
marcher il avait qualifié Daniel
Cohn-Bendit d'anarchiste
que vous avez dit sur 60 une notamment
alors Fabien Roussel qu'est-ce qu'on a
pensé de ce film consacré à Georges
Marchais est-ce qu'il avait vraiment
choisi son camp
quelqu'un il avait choisi pour vous
Georges Marchais le camp de la France la
France parce que
pour moi ce qui est important dans Parti
communiste français c'est français aussi
et Georges a fait le choix
à un moment donné d'écrire
une orientation pour le Parti communiste
français distingue des autres parties
communistes et notamment celui de l'URSS
et et de d'imprimer
la marque originale du Parti communiste
français dans l'histoire de notre pays
notamment de faire gagner la gauche
il a pris ses distances avec le Parti
communiste du nom surviétique et
donc effectivement il a été celui qui a
permis la victoire en 81 mais aussi pas
seulement d'avoir un programme à mon
avis le plus ambitieux qu'il n'y ait
jamais eu pour notre pays pour la gauche
à ce moment là bon tu t'es vite renier
par la suite mais et donc pour ça lui
l'équipe dirigeante qu'il y avait à
l'époque autour de lui ont écrit
l'histoire du Parti communiste français
avec son originalité en commémore aussi
avec ce film les 25 ans de la
disparition de de Georges Marchais je me
suis amusé à regarder ce qui avait été
dit il y a 5 ans sur Georges Marchais 20
ans après ça disparition il y avait
assez peu dommage rendu à Georges
Marchais à cette occasion il y a
maintenant cinq ans
parce que son bilan son héritage qui est
l'autre sujet du jour l'héritage laissé
par Georges Marchais était jugé comme
très mitigé et vous disiez il a pris ses
distances avec l'Union soviétique à
l'époque et c'est surtout que là-dessus
le que le bât blesse semble-t-il dans la
mémoire de certains aujourd'hui il
n'auraient pas pris suffisamment ces
distances à l'époque avec le avec les
Soviétiques
parce que d'abord parce que on garde en
mémoire les médias aiment bien le
rappeler cette interview terrible qu'il
fait depuis Moscou pour commenter
l'invasion en Afghanistan et ça ça a été
dévastateur tout le monde le reconnaît
lui il a reconnu bon voilà mais le
documentaire rappelle aussi qu'il fait
le choix bien avancé
distance avec le Parti communiste
français de décrire que tant que il n'y
avait pas des changements les relations
s'arrêteraient il a été à l'initiative
d'un Comité
pour la défense des droits de l'Homme
enfin bon il a été quand même très à
l'initiative dans ce domaine et donc
pour moi je d'abord quand on a été
dirigeant d'un parti aussi longtemps il
faut pouvoir prendre un personnage dans
son entier dans son entier et donc
forcément comment voulez-vous
différencier peut-être les périodes dans
les 21 ans de pouvoir ce que je veux
dire
restons humains
même quand on est un secrétaire national
un dirigeant d'un parti on reste un être
humain et comment peut-on juger un homme
ou une femme dirigeant d'un parti sur 30
ans
en disant que tout a été parfait
merveilleux nickel et c'est ça n'existe
pas et donc
voilà mais bon on va voir ce qu'on dise
les chiffres
de votre émission c'est un héritage
encombrant point d'interrogation quand
même il y a rien d'encombrant enfin je
veux dire moi le au contraire l'héritage
de Georges Marchais mais encore une fois
avec George il y avait beaucoup de
d'hommes et de femmes derrière la partie
avec beaucoup plus de militants
qu'aujourd'hui il y a 700 000 militants
c'est ce qui est dit dans ce domaine des
années 70 vous en vendiquez 41000 il y
avait des des dirigeants
importants des hommes des femmes et donc
c'est un bel héritage qu'ils nous ont
laissé au contraire et puis surtout des
scores impressionnants une influence
forte du Parti communiste français 15 et
demi en 81 aux élections européennes
deux ans avant il fait plus de 20% et
bien cette influence du Parti communiste
français dans le pays elle s'est
traduite par des conquêtes sociales
importantes et moi c'est le lien que je
fais entre influence du Parti communiste
français et conquête sociale et ça c'est
le plus beau des héritages et vous
évoquez des résultats électoraux et
c'est vrai que c'est important c'est la
seule chose qui compte finalement
parfois un dans l'engagement politique
des formations politiques Roland Carole
certains disent les détracteurs de
marché disent voilà marcher il a pris le
parti il était à 22 % il laisse le parti
en moins de 10%. c'est ça que le bilan
des chiffres électoraux disent de
Georges Marchais et de ce 21 ans passés
à la tête du PCF oui j'ai l'impression
d'être invité à une réunion de famille
je suis un peu embêté de
devoir dire que tout ça je comprends que
le temps des hommages arrive même pour
ceux qui ont échoué c'était quand même
des braves gens
mais Georges Marchais moi je l'ai c'est
bien connu comme politologue j'ai eu des
meilleures relations possibles avec lui
c'est un personnage
mais ça personnage qui a échoué c'est un
personnage qui a rendu son parti avec
deux fois moins de voix qu'il ne l'a
pris à l'organisation c'est un
personnage qui s'est à peu près trompé
sur toute la ligne aussi bien dans la
façon de faire de l'union de la gauche
que de la rompre que de s'y rallier dans
ces allers-retours envers le grand frère
soviétique voilà moi je dois dire que je
suis assez étonné qu'on puisse
aujourd'hui faire comme si ce grand
bonhomme car c'était un sacré bonhomme
avait été une espèce de d'entité
positive et pour les résultats
électoraux et pour les luttes sociales
je crois que le bilan est beaucoup plus
mitigé que cela
vedette de télévision incontestable et
encore j'y reviendrai plus ça a pu finir
par jour contre lui un homme politique
d'une vraie envergure
un courage réel des doutes réelles sur
certains aspects de sa biographie qui
continuent à exister voilà c'est un
personnage qui reste à mes yeux un tout
petit peu plus compliqué un tout petit
peu plus plat d'ombre et de lumière que
les hommages qui peuvent lui être rendus
de façon un peu
unanime désormais alors il y a plusieurs
causes identifiées à se déclin durant
cette période et qu'il a eu à gérer et
qui sont aussi pour beaucoup des
contraintes extérieures j'en ai noté
quelques-unes bon d'abord il y a
évidemment le poste 68 et l'intervention
à Prague des troupes soviétiques l'eau
rétrécissement progressif des classes
ouvrières au profit des classes moyennes
et ça s'est traduit par la montée en
puissance du Parti socialiste et de
François Mitterrand la chute du mur de
Berlin en 89 et puis la dislocation de
l'empire soviétique et la
désindustrialisation française voilà en
gros
ce qu'on peut mettre dans le cocktail
qui a eu à affronter aussi Georges
Marchais quelque chose qui m'a étonné
sans doute un parti pris j'ai ramener il
n'y a aucune image par exemple de la
chute du mur de Berlin dans ce dans ce
film c'est volontaire non il faut faire
des choix et j'ai évoqué cette période
là c'est ça se produit à un moment où
j'avais pas trop de commentaires à faire
sur sur Georges Marchais mais je vais
rebondir sur ce que dit Roland c'est
c'est très injuste me semble-t-il c'est
à dire qu'en effet marchait le Parti
communiste n'ont pas réussi à instaurer
le socialisme à la française donc de ce
point de vue là on peut considérer que
c'est un échec maintenant si aujourd'hui
nous avons cinq semaines de congés payés
grâce à l'arrivée de la gauche au
pouvoir si aujourd'hui il y a toute une
série de mesures sociales qui sont quand
même maintenues voir développer c'est
notamment parce que le Parti communiste
a réussi à pousser le Parti socialiste
dans ces retranchements donc c'est c'est
très injuste de ne prendre que la chute
incontestable en voie du Parti
communiste
avec tout Fabien Roussel pourrait dire
et je le dis à sa place que nous avons
encore un parti communiste en France
alors que nous n'avons plus en Italie en
Italie ou c'était presque un parti plus
puissant que le Parti communiste
français donc et qui sait émanciper lui
très clairement des Soviétiques dans les
années 70
une fois qu'il est mort d'avoir fini par
transmettre un parti qui est devenu le
Parti socialiste aujourd'hui donc il
faut resituer les choses moi ce qui me
frappe dans l'histoire de marché c'est
pour ça que je pense que on peut lui
rendre mage sans le réhabiliter on peut
lui rendre c'est que c'était un ouvrier
et un ouvrier qui avait réussi à monter
au plus haut de la de l'échelle
politique et sociale moi je suis frappé
d'abord de cette dimension là et il y a
quelqu'un qui nous dit très justement
dans le documentaire qu'on vient de voir
c'est que les gens qui aimaient marcher
les maps pas parce qu'il parlait pour
eux parce qu'il était comme et
dites-vous à quel moment est-ce qu'on
retrouvera dans la vie politique
française alors c'est un peu le cas avec
la dernière élection législative il y a
quand même des personnes aussi atypiques
que Madame kéké des exemples femmes de
ménage mais dites-vous à quel point ça
représenté pour beaucoup de gens un
encouragement extraordinaire d'avoir un
ouvrier et un ouvrier communiste qui
puisse parler finalement comme chacun
parlait à l'époque rien que pour ça je
trouve qu'il faut rendre hommage à
marcher oui il est resté ouvrier
jusqu'au moment où il est devenu
permanent
quoi vers 26 ans donc ça veut dire que
c'est une culture ouvrière c'est un
milieu ouvrier mais c'est quand même un
homme d'appareil l'essentiel de sa vie
alors beaucoup de gens moi je vois bien
le théâtre langue de ma femme qui était
secrétaire de section communiste il
avait sympathie pour le fait que c'était
un camarade ouvrier et en même temps il
avait pas d'illusion sur le fait que
il aura ajouté un peu quand il faisait
des fautes de grammaire c'était un peu
pour montrer que il n'était pas de
l'élite bourgeoises mais que il savait
très bien qu'il parlait pas comme ça
dans la vie voilà il y a eu aussi cette
espèce d'insistance à insister le
caractère ouvrière qui a un peu fait
oublier le caractère apparaître en tout
cas ça aurait été le dernier ouvrier
mais talon en l'occurrence à être à la
tête du PCF ensuite il y aura des
personnalités issues d'autres catégories
sociales je Robert Hue qui lui
succéderait était infirmier
donc vous savez les ouvriers aujourd'hui
c'est pas que ceux qui travaillent dans
les usines
à l'époque c'était beaucoup ça parce que
il y avait dans ce qui était dans la
fonction publique hospitalière ou dans
dans le tertiaire qui démarrait avait un
autre statut les instituteurs avaient un
autre statut mais aujourd'hui moi quand
je parle des ouvriers je parle autant de
ceux qui dans les usines que ceux qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux que ceux
qui travaillent dans les écoles que ceux
qui travaillent dans la fonction
publique que ce qu'ils travaillent dans
les services enfin quand même que les
paysans enfin aujourd'hui il y a une
classe ouvrière qui tutoie la classe
moyenne parce que parce que tellement on
a dévalorisé le travail enfin on
pourrait en parler en long en large mais
moi je comprends que vous vous y
retrouviez pas parce que effectivement
c'était un homme qui a défendu et la
classe ouvrière mais aussi des
propositions fortes qui ont été mises en
oeuvre quand même parce que il a mis
tout son poids et tout le poids du Parti
communiste français à cette époque là
comme c'est dit dans le documentaire
pour que la gauche l'emporte et c'est
vrai vous avez raison monsieur mineur il
a été l'artisan de cette victoire de la
gauche et quand même non mais pour les
ouvriers et pour tous les salariés
français la retraite à 60 ans on en
parle en ce moment c'est à cette époque
là quand même la retraite à 60 ans la
cinquième semaine des congés payés c'est
aussi à cette époque la hausse des
salaires
noter un petit peu que ce qui a été fait
à cette époque là quand même ont été un
bon en avant un progrès social pour une
majorité de Français et nous sommes
fiers d'avoir mené ce combat-là il y a
même une réforme importante c'est quand
même solidarité
c'est quand même passé c'est quand même
parce que Georges Marchais rond le
programme commun que la gauche arrive au
pouvoir non
c'est pas du programme commun en second
tour il permet la victoire Mitterrand et
dans la mise en oeuvre et le poids et le
poids théoriquement ça c'est pas ça
comme je voulais me le dire le poids de
Georges Marchais ou à l'élection
présidentielle fait que justement pour
l'emporter
Mitterrand il est bien obligé de faire
avec les communistes et de prendre
quatre ministres communistes dans son
gouvernement et avec un programme
ambitieux quand même nationalisation des
banques de l'industrie
quand même et rupture du
du programme commun en 77 par Georges
Marchais c'est ce que vous évoquez à
l'instant Roland Carole on va voir un
extrait du documentaire ça c'est le
marché médiatique et là il parle de
François mitrant
me dit dit que moi je trahis les
intérêts de la classe ouvrière
il est gentil avec moi moi quand je dis
l'unité voilà comment nous la voyons
dans l'intérêt des travailleurs et des
peuples moi c'est moi qui est
l'agresseur
voilà il y a une petite faute de
grammaire vous évoquiez c'est faute de
grammaire sur le plan de la
communication est-elle volontaire ou pas
on ne sait pas et puis alors ce fameux à
François mitrand évidemment pour parler
de François Mitterrand vous dites dans
votre documentaire en réalité ça a été
le premier communisme premier numéro à
communiste à être médiatique Georges
Marchais et c'est ce que garde
collectivement la plupart des Français
qui ont vécu cette période politique de
la France ils ont raison de retenir cet
aspect des choses je je le dis souvent
il y a la Cinquième République deux
hommes politiques qui ont été le plus
caricaturéité c'est de Gaulle et c'est
marcher ça dit quelque chose de marché
c'est qu'on est fait il a compris ce qui
était la télévision bien avant d’autre
aux hommes politiques il a compris
effectivement qu'il pouvait s'adresser
c'est ce qu'il disait à son fils qui
pouvait s'adresser en émission à des
milliers de personnes dans des centaines
de meetings qu'il aurait dû faire donc
c'est sûr qu'il a compris qu'on pouvait
faire 15 millions de téléspectateurs
sur des émissions comme carte sur table
tu vois si tout je me souviens de ces
émotions 15 millions à la télé plutôt
que comme vous dites 10000 dans un
métier les gens se réunissaient pour
regarder Georges Marchais ils avaient le
sentiment qu'il allait se passer quelque
chose et ce que je trouve simplement
injuste ce que j'ai voulu dire dans ce
documentaire c'est que c'est pas juste
d'en faire un clown médiatique c'était
une force médiatique mais c'était qu'un
des aspects du personnage le les autres
aspects c'était un très bon pourquoi
est-ce que le Parti communiste va le
choisir va le prendre va le prendre en
quelque sorte par la manche c'est parce
que déjà c'était un très bon orateur
dans son usine il y a une photo
malheureusement il y en a pas beaucoup
on le voit parler devant une centaine ou
150 ouvriers quand il était encore
prolos il était capable à ce moment-là
déjà c'est pour ça que le Parti
communiste va en faire un cadre donc
c'est vrai que c'est un aspect important
son côté médiatique mais ça ne se réduit
pas à ça mais c'est pas dans la culture
de votre partie ça Fabien rousselha le
numéro 1 il a il a pas à se mettre en
avant c'est pas du tout la culture du
PCF d'ailleurs très souvent c'était pas
le numéro 1 des du PCF qui se présentait
à la présidentielle c'était un autre
candidat
on fait des parallélisme entre vous et
Georges Marchais vous vous souvenez de
cet article de L'Express qui dit il fait
du neuf avec de l'ancien Fabien Roussel
le communiste bon marché bon évidemment
il y a un peu d'humour dans ce titre
mais l'échappe à personne que vous aussi
vous allez chercher à avoir une présence
médiatique avec le punch le même punch
la même présence physique c'est ce qu'on
disait concernant Georges Marchais sur
les plateaux télé vous êtes inspiré de
marché pour pour cet aspect là des
choses votre présence médiatique et
celle que vous représentez au nom de du
PCF aujourd'hui sur les plateaux de
télévision non mais ce que je note c'est
que c'est quand même la Cinquième
République qui
personnalise beaucoup la vie politique
et notamment l'élection présidentielle
l'hyper présidentialisation de la vie
politique quand même et depuis
d'ailleurs que les deux élections
présidentielles et législatives se
suivent enfin on a
personnalisé la vie politique à outrance
concentrer les pouvoirs dans un homme ou
une femme celui qui remporte l'élection
présidentielle et donc la vie politique
construit comme ça malheureusement nous
le dénonçons nous contestons cette cette
Constitution qui conduit à cela et moi
j'aimerais beaucoup plus que le pouvoir
repose sur le Parlement d'abord et sur
les élus du peuple dans le temps
médiatique n'est pas le temps politique
elle ne se construit pas comme ça et
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle que
l'élection présidentielle est une
élection ou les partis politiques ont
vocation à présenter leur programme et
le soumettre au débat des Français et au
choix des Français la manière de le
faire
vous avez des punchlines vous êtes
commencés à battu une réputation qui
ressemble un peu à celle de George
marchais sur les plateaux de télévision
que je reconnais dans le le parallèle
qui pourrait être fait c'est que quand
je connais son histoire il n'était pas
prédestiné il n'était pas destiné à
devenir secrétaire nationale il
travaillait était métallo et voilà et de
la même manière moi j'ai jamais imaginé
un plan de carrière j'ai jamais imaginé
que je serai secrétaire national de
demander à être élu député et à me
retrouver ici c'est la vie qui nous lui
qui l'a amené à ses responsabilités là
comme moi moi j'ai moi c'est trois mois
avant le congrès de 2018 que on m'a
proposé on m'a poussé à y aller moi j'ai
jamais demandé à faire tout ça après la
vie elle nous conduit là où on est et
puis peut-être ce que l'on a en commun
c'est que peut-être qu'on on a des
convictions et on les défend avec cœur
et avec passion avec sincérité on parle
comme on est voilà moi je suis quelqu'un
du Nord bon lui il n'était pas du Nord
alors vous dit dans une interview mais
premier meeting c'était que c'était 86
c'était la fête de l'Huma et et vous
disiez bah c'était pour moi un moment
d'apprentissage et vous aviez une petite
phrase d'ailleurs on ne faisait pas les
cons pendant
parce qu'il y avait une discipline il y
avait un respect du numéro 1 lorsqu'on a
la parole
c'est parce que on est on écoutait
c'était clair on comprenait on se on se
on se sentait respecter et donc c'était
voilà on écoutait comme comme on peut
être passionné ou concentré par un docu
par un film enfin c'était vivant enfin
les meetings ils étaient ils étaient
vivants on avait l'impression qu'on nous
parlait j'ai le même j'ai le même la
même exigence quand je fais des des
meetings quand j'organise la dans le
cadre de mon tour de France c'est de
parler aux gens voilà le nombre de
discours que l'on peut me préparer et où
je bifle et je barre parce que pour moi
c'est on parle des fois on a on parle
comme dans des tracts mais les gens
comprennent pas ça il faut leur parler
comme eux faut parler la même langue
voilà que ceux qui travaillent que des
retraités que des jeunes c'est pas
évident mais il faut le plus possible à
mon avis
baigner dans rester proche des gens pour
pouvoir parler comme tout le monde c'est
tout Roland Carole Georges Marchais bête
médiatique vous souhaitiez dire quelques
mots sur ce sujet tout à l'heure là oui
d'abord dire que en dehors de la bête
médiatique c'était un homme avec qui il
était agréable de converser et de
converser de choses sérieuses moi je
suis allé voir la première fois
professionnellement pour pouvoir faire
une enquête sur des militants
et donc les militants ne sont partis à
l'occasion d'un congrès il m'a accueilli
extrêmement gentiment dans son bureau il
m'a dit
c'est quoi le questionnaire je vais
montrer il m'a dit ça cette question
cette question je dis c'est pas non
c'est pas négociable puisque on l'a fait
dans les différents partis il m'a dit
les autres parties le font je lui ai dit
oui il m'a dit bah alors il y a pas de
problème allez-y voilà
une autre fois
elle tu sert le philosophe décider de
faire une série de papiers sur qui
gouvernent le Parti communiste français
qui l'a publié d'ailleurs et marché
Monique j'aimerais bien savoir de
répondre à cette question il y avait
quelque chose d'amusant de sympathique
devrait bon à la télé c'était vraiment
la bête médiatique et on regardait les
émissions de télé pour le plaisir de
regarder le marché vraiment c'était
évidemment très fort sur les militants
chez les sympathisants qui disaient il
va nous défendre qu'est-ce qui va
qu'est-ce qui va leur mettre à
Elkabbache et a du ML mais en même temps
il y avait cette espèce de plaisir du
spectacle et c'est ce qu'il a je crois
beaucoup porté vraiment un intérêt parce
que la télévision pendant ce temps-là
n'arrêtait pas de progresser en
influence dans le pays et je pense que à
la fin dans les dernières années je me
souviens de certaines études
qualitatives ou chez des ouvriers et
notamment chez des ouvrières certaines
nous disaient
il finit par faire du mal à l'ouvrier en
donnant cette impression exagérée et
donc c'est là que je pense que c'est
comme toujours quand on en fait bien
quand on en fait trop
on risque un peu de temps en temps comme
dirait l'autre quand les bornes sont
franchies il y a plus de limite voilà et
ça peut peut-être contribuer un peu à la
fin à se retourner un petit peu contre
lui l'héritage
Georges Marchais vous avez pu
tester un petit peu les choses auprès à
la fois de Marie-Georges Buffet qui est
dans ce documentaire soit bien Roussel
vous y êtes également dans ce film et
Robert Hue et c'est Robert Huc qui est
le premier à succéder à George marchais
bon qu'est-ce qu'ils ont pensent de cet
héritage laissé par Georges Marchais
c'était pas facile ils l'ont eu marchait
le lâche le pouvoir à la tête du PC F en
94 le mur est tombé depuis cinq ans mais
ce qu'ils en pensent de ce fameux
héritage la ceux que vous avez rencontré
a commencé par Robert Hue et
Marie-Georges Buffet il y a pas de doute
qu'il y a un avant et après George
marchais si on regarde les grands
dirigeants du Parti communiste de
l'époque première du parti ce sont des
gens qui ont été formés quasiment comme
des bolcheviks ce sont les du ce sont
les Torres ce sont les trasuites qui
étaient d'ailleurs de grands hommes
c'est très utile était un type
formidable parlait crochet va le
décrocher était un type tout à fait
étonnant et c'est sûr que à partir de
marché on passe à un autre type de
dirigeant donc Fabien Roussel est un des
exemples mais d'abord ils sont tous très
différents les uns des autres alors
qu'il y avait une certaine homogénéité
même si chaque être humain est différent
il y avait une certaine homogénéité ils
sont tous très différents les uns des
autres les parties les dirigeants du
parti et puis ils ont effectivement à
faire face à quelque chose que ne
connaissait pas la première grande
génération
ils ont à faire face effectivement à un
déclin du communisme dans l'idéologie
dominante c'est vrai que la chute du de
l'Union soviétique donc que personne ne
peut regretter en même temps a fait
chuter toute une série d'idéos et même
dans le vocabulaire aujourd'hui quand
vous dites classe ouvrière on vous
regarde avec des grands yeux mais de
quoi vous parlez quand on dit exploiter
moi je suis d'une génération où on
parlait des exploiteurs et des exploités
aujourd'hui les dirigeants du Parti
communiste comme tous les dirigeants de
gauche ont faire face aussi à cette
situation post chute du Mur post
d'échéance du Parti communiste
soviétique et donc c'est une génération
qui doit se débattre finalement avec une
idéologie dominante qui est beaucoup
plus à droite à l'époque de marché il y
avait l'idée d'un monde meilleur
aujourd'hui ça devient beaucoup plus
difficile les gens ont l'impression que
la société dans laquelle nous vivons
c'est la société dans laquelle on vivra
jusqu'à la fin des temps donc je crois
qu'ils ont
se rappeler ce qui était marcher c'est
aussi se rappeler une période du Parti
communiste ou des centaines de milliers
de gens étaient convaincus qu'ils
arriveraient au pouvoir j'ai rappelé ça
dans le film grâce à Elsa faussillon
plus jeune député que que les anciens du
Parti communiste qui disaient mais je
n'arrive pas à comprendre comment le
Parti communiste n'est pas arrivé au
pouvoir en 70 c'était dire la force
l'idéal qui a servi surtout un
Mitterrand paradoxalement vous vous avez
décidé de régénérer cette idéologie
communiste c'est Dieu sait si c'est pas
facile c'était pas facile pour vous
prédécesseurs
mais vous l'avez fait en étant candidat
à la présidentielle de de 2022 parce que
ni en 2012 ni en 2017 le PCF n'avait de
représentants à l'élection
présidentielle
en 2002 hein
pour vous y alliez alors c'était quoi
l'idée là c'était de remettre au goût du
jour peut-être en allant piocher
d'ailleurs dans l'idéologie le fameux
communisme français prenait par Georges
Marchais c'était peut-être pour essayer
de reconquérir des voix avec une partie
du logiciel lors du marché je rejoins ce
que vient de dire j'ai un milliard c'est
que quand même la perte d'idéal
d'espoir elle est forte dans le pays en
général noir c'est noir comme chantait
Johnny Hallyday mais c'est ça c'est le
désespoir généralisé et je l'ai ressenti
avec force quand nous avons décidé aux
élections présidentielles de de retenir
comme slogan et comme programme les
jours heureux mais on m'a dit un peu de
malade les jours heureux enfin il y a la
guerre et à la crise etc mais c'est
impossible mais si c'est possible et on
veut continuer de croire et encore
aujourd'hui à croire à des croire à se
battre pour des réformes heureuses de
progrès pour les gens car nous
produisons suffisamment de richesses
pour cela et j'aime rappeler le
programme des jours heureux de 45 quand
même la France et puis alors vous le
faites en rappelant la valeur du travail
la souveraineté nationale le patriotisme
républicain mais on a plus le droit de
parler de bonheur de travail
d'émancipation de dignité humaine c'est
comme si tout ça c'était barré et il
fallait accepter notre sort et c'est
pour ça que 45 la France est exangue en
ruine on sort de la guerre et là pendant
que l'on fait la résistance des hommes
des femmes dans divers d'opinions
diverses écrivent ce programme des jours
heureux et ils le mettent en œuvre en 45
dans un gouvernement d'union nationale
on crée la sécurité sociale on crée EDF
GDF Marcel Paul enfin et aujourd'hui
c'est réformes qui ont vécu pour
certains d'entre elles jusqu'à
maintenant c'est le peu de progrès
encore c'est services publics cette
sécurité sociale qui nous reste et bien
oui je veux continuer de défendre un
idéal de progrès de fraternité humaine
de réponses aux besoins de tous on en a
tellement besoin et donc je marchais
est-ce qu'il y a du George marchais dans
ce que vous proposez aujourd'hui il y a
du George marcher dans le Parti
communiste français c'est quand même
c'est parce que nous sommes nous sommes
nous sommes issus de cette histoire là
aussi d'ailleurs entre 45 et aujourd'hui
je prends 45 parce que je fais référence
au programme des jours heureux mais
assez grande réforme qui ont montré que
c'était possible quand même je repense à
l'énergie au programme nucléaire etc je
donc entre 45 et aujourd'hui il y a
combien de générations il y a combien de
les gens d'hommes politiques si peu en
somme et donc pour moi on est le Parti
communiste français s'inscrit dans cette
dans cette histoire là encore
aujourd'hui et il est important dans le
monde morose résigné dans lequel on vit
d'apporter cette espoir voilà avec
toujours autant de force et de passion
30 secondes ça sera la fin de l'émission
Roland Carole c'est le déplacement du
vote ouvrier vers le Front national puis
le rassemblement rassemblement national
qui aura aussi marqué l'évolution
non il y a eu de la politique française
et parce que majoritairement ils
s'abstiennent l'abstention est
majoritaire
vous avez apporté une réponse tous les
deux d'abord il y a une différence de
l'analyse même des classes de la société
française monsieur Roussel a raison de
dire que la classe ouvrière
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas la classe
ouvrière dire 20 ou 30 ans elle s'est
complexifiée elle est plus aussi
homogène mais il existe évidemment comme
classe merci de le dire et d'un autre
côté il y a à la fois en effet d'anciens
électeurs de gauche socialistes ou
communiste qui ont qui se sont mis à
voter pour le Front national ou pour le
rassemblement national et qui le font
toujours et ça se voit très clairement
dans l'ancien bastions ouvriers mais il
y a aussi ce phénomène absolument
écrasant notamment chez les jeunes et
notamment chez les jeunes des catégories
populaires d'une abstention rejet de la
politique qui est l'obstacle principal
pour l'ensemble des forces de gauche et
notamment pour le parti communiste
ça sera le mot de la fin vraiment un
grand merci à tous les trois
spécialement Merci à VOUS Gérard Miller
de nous avoir proposé ce documentaire et
en exclusivité sur LCP pour cette
émission des Madoc vos réactions ça sera
sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
j'espère que vous serez tous les trois
là également pour réagir à ce que sont
les et à mon avis elles vont pas manquer
la suite de cette émission merci à sel
massali qui par ailleurs m'a aidé comme
à l'habitude d'ailleurs à préparer cette
émission puis je vous donne pour
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]